so I'm here doing it today hackle
clubbers workshop and what that means is
a bunch of people that are normally
developers building systems have
spending a couple of days braking
systems a lot so that they can stop
other people from doing so the workshops
are good because everyone gets to work
together talk with each other talk to me
we interact a lot and that means we have
a lot of good discussion we go
off-script I mean all the talks and
stuff that we do it in DC or awesome I
have a lot of fun doing those they're
kind of carefully orchestrated and
they're a bit of a show but the
workshops are very kind of our lives all
right like readings are really like
doing these workshops is there very
organic and casual and we have good
chests about seeing people sort of say
what about this or what about that and
it becomes a very sort of interactive
experience and you know everyone gets
along really well there's lots of
interesting people and ideas and it's
just a totally different kind of way of
interacting than the rest of the
conference and they're they're both
awesome in their own right but I love
your militia